how you feeling you've got a bit of a
sore head today
a little bit fuzzy yes I cannot tell a
lie what was it like that moment I mean
I know you performed in the fan Zone uh
before the moment where you knew this
was the first European title in a
generation but what was that moment like
that moment where suddenly all those
fans knew that that that was it their
their trophy their trophy their future
had just changed
it was the most unbelievable moment uh
electric atmosphere in the stadium
um I had my brother who's a big hammer
as well my son my 17 year old boy had my
best friend and his boy with me we were
all in the stadium together and it was
like I can't even explain uh how
incredible it was you know it's been
it's been since
1976 uh that West Ham have won a a
European title so uh yeah it's a long
time coming and how about the fans
amazing yeah I could see the pictures
there playing under me here yeah I mean
incredible absolutely that was probably
one of the greatest games I've ever
played honestly 25
000 uh you know people there all sea of
Claritin blue uh it was that there were
bubbles everywhere
uniting your passions in life music with
your with your football team so and
quite something to say that was your
favorite uh favorite gig that you've
ever performed homes tell me about the I
guess psychologically those fans now
what does that do to a to a club going
from where they were before now to
holding this trophy what does that mean
well the thing is about West Ham is
we're not used to winning trophies
certainly this generation you know so
for us we're all the West Ham fans
around that we're meeting around the
streets of Prague everybody's kind of
like uh did that actually happen uh am I
am I am I dreaming you know that's kind
of the way we all feel we're just uh
we're on cloud nine to be honest with
you it was such an amazing night
um and to see all the players we stayed
behind um to watch the players on the
pitch with their families and dancing to
the crowd and uh kind of acknowledging
the West Ham faithful you know and it
was it was a truly beautiful moment it
really was there were there were some
concerns about Western fans uh behavior
before the match took place in the end
did you see any bad behavior or was it
all fairly calm
no we've only seen uh we've only seen a
lot of love around town to be honest
with you and so there's a lot of really
great people here as a real kind of
family uh kind of feeling about the
community in West Ham um obviously
there's always going to be a few bad
eggs here and there um and I heard about
that we never saw any to be quite honest
with you
um and uh you know I've been here for
three days now so
um the whole time we've been here it's
just been it's been fantastic people are
just really lovely and for hammers like
you is there a concern now that you've
gone up in the world the club's gone up
in the world you might lose Declan rice
well I think that's a done deal to be
quite honest with you Bill unfortunately
uh none of us hammers want to hear that
the the truth but uh I think Declan rice
is is moving on it's uh it's sad to say
but it looks like he's gone out on a
high he's certainly certainly gone out
on a high and uh your performance as
well will have been sort of married up
with that amazing moment now for for all
history Chesney Hawks uh obviously the
pop star but also the West Ham supporter
really really lovely to talk to you
thanks for making the time and enjoy the
rest of your time
thank you